dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly shown IFA here as we
have seen in earlier episodes of the
series neural networks are remarkably
efficient tools to solve a number of
really difficult problems the first
applications of neural networks usually
revolved around classification problems
classification means that we have an
image as an input and the output is
let's say a simple decision whether it
depicts a cat or a dog the input will
have as many nodes as there are pixels
in the input image and the output will
have two units and we'll look at the one
of these two that fires the most to
decide whether it thinks it is a dog or
a cat between these two there are hidden
layers where the neural network is asked
to build an inner representation of the
problem that is efficient at recognizing
these animals so what is an autoencoder
an autoencoder is an interesting variant
with two important changes first the
number of neurons is the same in the
input and the output therefore we can
expect that the output is an image that
is not only the same size as the input
but actually is the same image now this
normally wouldn't make any sense why
would we want to invent a neural network
to do the job of a copying machine so
here goes the second part we have a
bottleneck in one of these layers this
means that the number of neurons in that
layer is much less than we would
normally see therefore it has to find a
way to represent this kind of data the
best it can with a much smaller number
of neurons if you have a smaller budget
you have to let go of all the fluff and
concentrate on the bare essentials
therefore we can't expect the image to
be the same but they are hopefully quite
close these autoencoders are capable of
creating sparse representations of the
input data and can therefore be used for
image compression I consciously avoid
saying they are useful for image
compression autoencoders offer no
tangible advantage over classical image
compression algorithms like JPEG however
is a cramp of comfort many different
variants exist that are useful for
different
tasks other than compression there are
denoise encoder encoders that after
learning these sparse representations
can be presented with noisy images as
they more or less know how this kind of
data should look like they can help in
denoising these images that's pretty
cool for starters what is even better is
a variant that is called the variational
auto encoder that not only learns these
sparse representations but can also draw
new images as well we can for instance
ask it to create new handwritten digits
and we can actually expect the results
to make sense there is an excellent blog
post from Francoise Shirley the creator
of the amazing carrots library for
building and training neural networks
make sure to have a look with these
examples we were really only scratching
the surface and I expect quite a few
exciting autoencoder applications to pop
up in the near future as well I cannot
wait to get my paws on those papers
hopefully you fellow scholars are also
excited if you are interested in
programming especially in Python make
sure to check out the channel of semtex
for tons of machine learning programming
videos and more thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time